how to work with virtual assistants
i got a great question recently from one
of my youtube subscribers
love you guys neil who wrote in that he
said he hired a virtual assistant
and is having a hard time keeping her
busy and trusting her and wanted my
advice on what to do
so here's what he wrote he said hey evan
i have a virtual assistant and don't
seem to keep her busy
even though i'm always inundated with
work this brings me to my question
how can you figure out what to delegate
and trust that the person to whom you
delegate will do it
correctly also how do i get myself out
of the mode of thought
it'll take me so long to explain how to
do it i'll just do it myself
this is a fantastic question because
a big problem for entrepreneurs is
realizing that you know
i need to i need to bring on a team i
need people to help me to build this
thing i can't do everything myself
but finding the right person and then
training them and working with them
can be so time consuming and then what
if they leave
then then you're stuck doing everything
all over again it's just a big waste of
time so it's getting through that first
hire
that first successful hire and often it
is on the admin side when you can get
through that
then you're on your path for big success
but i know it's a huge pain point for a
lot of entrepreneurs
so here's how to do it here's here's how
i've always done it especially on
administrative stuff number one is start
part-time
i never start a new admin staffer
full-time it always starts on a
part-time basis
for a couple reasons one it's to try
each other out
okay so it's been great we've
interviewed great they love it
they see what they can do you know you
see a lot of potential with them
fantastic but we don't jump in full time
i want to test them out i want to see
how they actually work
in the environment and i don't want to
be so
bogged down with training and supporting
this person that i can't actually go out
and do
the rest of my stuff i need to grow my
business so what i'll usually do is find
whatever the easiest thing is to do that
can get off my plate that i
can explain quickly to this person that
they can come on board
and do it they start seeing immediate
results
and that's my starting point so what
happens from there they get some
confidence
they can can you know build up the skill
sets a little bit they start saving me
time right and when they start saving me
time i see they're doing a good job
i have more time to invest into doing
more with them and so i'll think of new
projects
and more issues that they can get
involved in and so i slowly build up and
that may lead to
a full-time job as an admin assistant
or it may mean that they work 10 hours a
week or 20 hours a week or
just as an on as needed basis right it
doesn't necessarily have to be
full time but if you're struggling to
find full-time hours maybe
you don't just make it easier for
yourself and start smaller
start with five hours or ten hours a
week little projects and then build
yourself
up the second thing is record your
processes
and so you have to understand that not
every project
is great to be outsourced to virtual
assistants sometimes you need people who
are in-house and sometimes you need to
do it yourself just depending on what it
is
the projects that are best suited
towards virtual assistants
are ones that can be done online and
that are repeated
so if you find yourself doing the same
thing over and over and over and over
again
that's the kind of thing that you can
either automate
so i always look to automation first
software tools something to do it
automatically but if i can't then
delegate to
an admin assistant and what i usually do
to explain it
is i'll make a video so i'll explain
what i'm doing so here's what i'm doing
i am building this list and i
pull up my camtasia software it
basically records your screen on your
computer
and you have a microphone and you can
speak into it and explain what you're
doing
and i'll show how i do this process
and then they have the video so then i
don't need to write a step-by-step guide
because it's in
the video and you can build a library of
all the videos that they can look at
and it's easy to get them trained that
way without you having to
create extra work for yourself so as
you're doing it just record your screen
that i found super helpful the last
thing that i found really interesting
and really valuable as i've built up my
team
my so my number three tip is have
passion projects
i always try to encourage the people on
my team to come up with a project that
they can work on
that supports the mission of the
business
but is not something that i've given
them to do and so
this encourages them to learn more about
what we do it's never they get
so it's never something they get within
the first week or first month usually
takes a few months to get into it
they understand how the business works
and they start seeing ways
that the business could be better and
the more they can tie their passions
into what
your business is all about it's going to
make them feel happier
and you also have new projects happening
with your business
so i got this idea from google where
they give uh
workers you know 20 of their time to
work on their own
passion projects that still fits within
kind of google's scope
so you know if you want to if you want
to be a baker
you know there's not a lot i can do to
help you with that in my business but if
you want to do something else that
relates to entrepreneurs if it's build a
form or
whatever it is you can do it and
empowering your workers
to come up with projects and ideas that
excite them keep them tied to you longer
and and build amazing things for your
company so if this person's been with
you for a while and you trust them and
you like them you know them and they're
building up their skills
it might be something to look at too
giving them a passion project to work on
or having them come up with one given
the option and see what they come back
with and see if there's something in
there that they can build to help you
grow your business to the next level so
that's my advice for working with
virtual assistants i know it can be
frustrating i know it can be hard i know
you feel like you're doing so much work
yourself but you have to get through
this
grind you have to get through having
that first
employee and and it may not work like a
lot of entrepreneurs
they hire and then that person leaves
and the higher that person leaves and
you feel like
i'm just going to do this myself this is
ridiculous but to build
something strong to create your movement
you need to have a team and so you have
to have the courage
and the fortitude and the the conviction
to stay through this
to have not just one person but a whole
team of people working under you
believe for those of you watching like
the video please give it a thumbs up
below
let me know what you think leave a
comment underneath you have a question
for me put in the comments
and i'll make a video response just like
this one and click on my face if you
want to see
more videos like this and subscribe to
the channel thank you guys so much
you are awesome and i'll see you soon